quand tu as rencontré celle qui allait
devenir sa femme francine qui bien sûr
avait peur de cette image sur fabriquer
de playboy qui était la sienne qu'est ce
que tu lui disais
je voulais te dire que je t'attends
et tant pis si le perds mon temps ça je
lui ai pas dit mais je le dis je
t'attends jeu datant tout le temps ça on
veut décourager pourtant
et c'est là que tu lui a promis de
torrents j'ai un petit peu des voitures
c'est à dire les copains les boîtes de
nuit les
castels et tout ça bien sûr je lui ai
dit
je te promets le sel
au baiser la babouche
je te promets le miel à la main qui de
touches je te promets le ciel
dessus
la couche des fleurs et des ventes elles
pour que tes lui soient tous
les fleurs et des dentelles et elle
était comme en france in sur les pistes
de ski elle était si jolie
que je n'osais
elle était si jolie
ce ne peut
les
elle atteint trop j'allais
quand le vent l'eau
elle était si jolie
je
n'oublie
belle mémoire et après toutes ces années
tulle m comme en français moi j'ai les
terriens voilà aujourd'hui elle est le
garder le sommet de mai lui je laime
amour
dis-moi sascha klein connu quand même
pas mal de filles à travers toutes ces
années mais si tu devais définir
francine d'un seulement je le sais sa
façon d'être à moi parfois ou des plaies
retour elle et moi le silence se fait
mais
ma préférence à moi
alors maintenant avec les hauts et les
bas de l'existence les enfants sont
grands tous les deux ça va très bien 1
qu'est ce que tu lui dis la belle vie
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux